effectivement vous le disiez vous même
en début de cette interview beaucoup de
critiques
là on en passe et des meilleurs vous
seriez devenu national il sera soumis ce
passéisme manipulateur vendu à l'ultra
droite
j'ai même lu fasciste bon on vous a
qualifié même de revues nazi avant même
sa publication
cette voie là cette violence dans les
propos ça veut dire quoi que vous faites
peur vous inquiétez pas dans quelle ils
se trouvent
c'est à dire si objectivement j'ai eu ma
biographie mois elle témoigne pour moi
j'ai fait une université populaire
quand j'ai fait des universités
populaires du goût j'ai fait du
bénévolat prendre toute ma vie j'ai dans
la ville que j'habitais à argentan dans
une sous préfecture des expositions de
peinture pendant pendant dix ans n'a
jamais parlé de ces choses là je me suis
fait mettre à la porte de france culture
par le pouvoir les journaux de longs
pourparlers n'ont plus pu dire une
université populaire qui existait un
camp a été interdite par le maire de
caen par les universitaires de caen mais
ça on n'a évidemment jamais parler non
plus et puis d'un seul coup on découvre
que je suis nazi formidable c'est sûr
que j'ai écrit et plus d'une centaine de
livres j'ai beaucoup parlé et je demande
à ce que depuis 1989 date de mon
apparition dans le don dans le monde
littéraire dans le monde des idées on
trouve une seule phrase qui vont trouver
que je défends les chambres à gaz des
étoiles juive les déportations les camps
de concentration l'idée que j'aurais dit
des juifs que c'était une race
inférieure et qu'il faudrait restaurer
la supériorité d'une race aryenne ou ce
genre de choses c'est ça un nazi alors
si moi je suis un nazi nazisme le
nazisme c'est pas si grave
mais pourquoi tant de droit d'être
négationniste et révisionniste dans ces
cas là c'est pas grave le nazisme si
c'est michel entre les franchement c'est
expliquer la violence à ses propos
contre vous mais fait les frais alors
ils ont peur ils détiennent les médias
et détiennent le pouvoir économique ils
détiennent le pouvoir médiatique il
détient des droits universitaires comme
le pouvoir dans l'édition dans les
revues partout ils font la loi partout
partout partout et ils ne veulent pas
que quelqu'un arrive en disant mais nous
on est libre on n'appartient pas des
banquiers on appartient pas de
milliardaires on n'appartient pas des
publicitaires on appartient au lecteur
tous sont les lecteurs qui font notre
notre existence je la prends bien mais
ils ont beaucoup d'argent que ce normal
michel onfray il aime beaucoup d'argent
oui j'ai fait à peu près une trentaine
d'années de bénévolat
pour quelqu'un qui aime beaucoup
l'argent et puis qu'on dise parce que
dans l'extrait ci a effectivement un
anonyme extrêmement courageux qui dit
que je ne suis intéressé que par
l'argent mais j'aimerais bien que ce
monsieur dit il est intéressé par
l'argent parce que voilà lui fait des
queues de confiance car je peux vous
donner des noms de collègues qui font
des différences à 15000 et 20000 euros
ou des gens qui partent huit jours en
croisière sur un bateau avec leurs
femmes parfois avec leurs maîtresses et
parfois avec leurs enfants et qui sont
payés 50 ou 60 mille euros pour aller
faire des reçus ces diverses et
multiples et qui parfois utilise
quelques-uns de mes travaux sans les
citer et qu'on le dise effectivement
qu'on dise jalons free il a fait des
conférences payer vingt mille euros pour
des jeux parfois des pharmaciens des
notaires qu'on fasse savoir que j'ai été
le philosophe de service sur des
croisières
et puis à ce moment là les joueurs ont
le droit de dire que je suis un
et que l'argent m'intéresse je demande
juste des preuves
je veux bien être un nazi mais je vous
dis il va falloir qu'on m'explique où
quand comment de quelle manière avec
quels textes qu'elle livre quel
engagement on voit simplement qu'il ya
une panique totale de tous ces gens qui
sortent du même terrier et les gens ne
sont pas dupes ils découvrent
effectivement qu'il y a un pouvoir qu'il
tient qui tient le peuple sous sa botte
et comme on le dit nous ils ont les
autres dans l'équipe un front populaire
et avec mon ami stephen sinon bah
évidemment on fait peur à des gens qui
n'ont pas intérêt à ce qu'on dise que le
roi est nu